congratulations and I'm excited about
the new song and the guys were here
earlier and they told me that you think
you've heard Christina Aguilera sing
before and you've never heard her sing
until now oh I love them so much there's
such talented songwriters and what they
exude is just there's something so
humble and so unassuming and the songs
that they write they they ask for
nothing but they've reached so many I
mean when I do say something in my
concerts it's just a song where everyone
you can feel the connection and the love
and that's what we're bringing tonight
tell me about this fashion you look
insane
it's the archives of Jean Paul Gautier
so let's go ta it's it's gorgeous I've
had this actually on hold for me for a
while and I'm bringing it out tonight so
what is it like when you walk on the
American Music Awards red carpet because
you have such history with the show and
we've sort of every year that I see you
one of my first interviews ever ten
years ago was you on this carpet so it's
just crazy like you're the queen thank
you it's amazing because I do look back
throughout my somebody sent me they were
like we should do a slideshow of all
your looks on the America Music Awards
and I was looking back and I was like
wow girl about that woman of a thousand
looks so yeah so this is a new chapter
and I'm excited my birthday is this
month so there's a lot to celebrate 20
years of the original album is this so
it's a lot to thank be thankful for and
to celebrate do you remember about that
girl back then uh well I'm she was just
ready she was doing everything being
worked a lot I mean I've been working
for my whole life so to be here now is a
grown woman and to reflect on that time
and to just be here now and as a woman
so assured of myself and you know now I
have kids that can watch at home so it's
really exciting thank you
[Music]